joining us now with reaction the author
of trial of the Century Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett along with former
acting attorney general Matt Whitaker
Matt I'm going to start with you you
hear Merrick Garland if the statement
about the importance of the Department
of Justice of course it is and that's
why we're concerned that's why
everybody's upset with what's going on
what he said was true he's attaching it
to the presumption then that you should
not criticize it because it's so
important with everything we've now
heard Matt uh what what do you what's
your take on this
yeah well good to be with you tonight
Tammy you know this is directed to
people like me and Greg that have been
calling into question uh these deals
that were made with Hunter Biden the
investigation into Donald Trump and so
many other investigations that
demonstrate a two-tiered system of
justice and you know I watched the
Attorney General he seems very
thin-skinned and can't take the
criticism I mean if he is above board
then then he should have nothing to
worry about I worry the most especially
now it's very clear that maybe Garland's
not the one putting his thumb on the
scale but the assistant attorney
generals for criminal the tax division
and these U.S attorneys in California
and in DC that appear to have prevented
Weiss from bringing this case that he
wanted to bring and it has now had to
fold up tent and take two misdemeanor
charges it's really it's a shameful
chapter for the Department of Justice it
is and you know Greg I know our viewers
are smart and they're reading everything
and this it's there's just so much to
look at when it comes to the nature of
what happened with this case you've been
of course on this if for years the
nature of a double standard of an
unfairness in the legal system and yet
last night you've got that same attorney
general even willing to be in the same
room with a man that is had faced if
pleading guilty to charges we had the
Whistleblower report no one seemed to
have a problem with that it's it's an
outrageous insult to the American people
as though who cares what we think
you know it was kind of like the wedding
reception and The Godfather movie where
all the Thugs and Crooks gathered
together to celebrate look uh the head
of the Crooked organization is Merrick
Garland and his denials are farcical in
a testimony by the whistleblowers is
compelling they cite specific actions
that were taken to shut down felony
charges to protect Hunter Biden and in
turn Joe Biden I mean how else do you
explain an absurd plea to two minor tax
misdemeanors in the face of clear
felonious conduct that would land
anybody else in prison I mean how do you
rationalize a five-year investigation
that ignored Brazen corruption they
weren't even allowed to open the laptop
so Garland's denials are completely
dishonest the IRS found that you know
Hunter cheated the government out of
more than 8 million in unreported income
from his many influence peddling schemes
yet most of that is not charged just a
sliver of it or a couple of misdemeanors
I mean look these IRS agents they're
supervisory officials they were the ones
who were present during these pivotal
meetings when their requests for example
for warrant-based raids on Hunter's home
and storage unit were denied and they
sat there and they watched and listened
as this assistant U.S attorney says yes
we we do have more than enough probable
cause to do it but we won't because the
Optics would be bad well gee the doj
didn't give a damn about the Optics when
they rated Mar-A-Lago Garland you know
claims also that two Biden appointed U.S
attorneys in California and Washington
didn't stop felonious prosecutions well
he wasn't there the IRS agents were yeah
you know Matt what's fascinating here is
that you've got his complete denials on
this aspect where we have any these
whistleblowers just so that the viewer
realizes as as Greg noted these are high
up people these aren't you know somebody
who we wouldn't know or didn't really
have access or overheard a conversation
these are individuals who were involved
and have since then were removed from
the investigation so that they know
directly uh it do you think that that
when it comes to the nature of this
because we're not even having an
investigation into you've got an extra
eight million dollars that we're not
there's no investigation into who did
that come from and was that bribery we
also have lost that unless that's
continuing and that seems to be
debatable
we have and and to the point you know
they these were people that were at the
table but this is not their first rodeo
I mean one was a supervisory special
agent so they have done plenty of
criminal tax cases they've done plenty
of felony criminal tax cases they know
how people are treated under similar
circumstances and not only did they
complain to the investigation team you
know they took it to Congress because
they felt that compelled that this was
so out of the mainstream of how cases
like this have been done and should be
done that they felt that Congress and
the American people should know how
extraordinary this case this case is and
they were punished they were taken off
the case they were removed from the
investigative team for raising this
concern I mean this is this this case as
we're as we learn and we need to you
know Congress needs to get the U.S
attorney for Delaware Mr Weiss in front
of them as soon as possible so and hear
exactly what he has to say because he is
the one that knows what he was able to
do and what he wasn't able to do and who
prevented him from doing it yes exactly
you know it seems to me it's similar
that it's like the Edwards Snowden case
who watched James Clapper lie to
Congress directly about what the NSA was
collecting on the American people he
knew that was false and that's what
compelled him to come out now of course
we know what happened to him that was
another message to whistleblowers
gentlemen thank you very much clearly
we're just at the beginning of this this
is not going to be the end Greg and Matt
thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else